mais d'abord direction donc la cour
d'appel d'Orléan où se tenait
aujourd'hui le 3e et dernier jour du
procès du touranjo accusé d'avoir
étouffé une vieille dame avec une
madeleine les jurés doivent aujourd'hui
se prononcer sur l'innocence ous la
culpabilité de l'accusé que c'est-il
réellement passé dans la chambre de la
nonagére le 13 mai 2019 l'accusé a-t-il
volontairement tué Yvette brissé dont il
avait acheté la maison enviagé ce matin
il était appelé à la barre Lucas
Chopin ce 3e et dernier jour de procès
en appel a débuté par l'audition d'alin
accusé d'avoir tué Yvette 92 ans en
l'étouffant avec des madeleines pendant
près de 3H l'homme de 64 ans s'est
exprimé pleurant à plusieurs reprises
expliquant avoir effectivement donner un
morceau de madeleine à la nonagénre et
niant encore et encore l'avoir tué une
question que son avocat a justement tenu
à lui poser parce que l'enquêteur ce
qu'il n'avait pas fait en première
instance a fait 7 à 10 hypothèses sur
les conditions dans lesquelles monsieur
monur jcelin aurait pu tuer madame Briss
parce que c'est clairement la question
qui lui est posée et je pense que il
faut arrêter de se cacher derrière son
petit doigt il faut poser la question
aux gens ça avait été posé à des témoins
est-ce que vous pensez qu'il l'a fait et
ben moi je la pose au principal
intéressé et et en le mettant en
difficulté et en l'accablant un peu
c'est en le poussant dans ses
retranchements pour voir si oui ou non
il y a quelque chose qui peut sortir et
il maintient je n'ai pas tué madame BR
il apparaît qu'au moment d' fait Alain
jouscelin effectué des recherches pour
acquérir un nouveau bien immobilier un
bien qu'il aurait pu financer en
revendant la maison qu'il avait acheté
envagé à Ivet 24 ans plus tôt
aujourd'hui 4 ans après les fait
l'accusé est revenu à plusieurs reprises
sur des détails de cette soirée du 3 mai
2019 horaire déplacement observation
plusieurs éléments demeurent flous ce
que n'a pas manqué de relever l'avocat
des partis civiles je trouve qu'il n'a
pas apporté toutes les réponses ou en
tout cas pas des réponses satisfaisantes
à beaucoup de choses on a pu aussi noter
que ces réponses ont plus évoluer au
cours de la procédure au cours de la
garde à vue au cours de ses auditions
y compris à l'audience on a des réponses
qui ont encore évolué donc la question
c'est la vérité il y en a pas 50 soit la
vérité elle est simple et pourquoi il ne
l'a dit pas dès le départ soit ses
réponses est voulu mais à ce momentl la
question c'est quelle est leur
authenticité au moment où je vous parle
les pldoirie se poursuiv au tribunal
d'Orléan le verdict pourrait tomber
tardant la
nuit et le parquet vient d'annoncé qu'il
requérait 20 ans de prison à l'encontre
de
l'accusé